prove them right because there's an end
in your life and it's coming sooner than
you think it goes by like this just
yesterday Max was six years old in the
car wash he's going off to college next
year just yesterday she was eight months
old now she's got a boyfriend just
yesterday I was a young cool guy just
yesterday me and my girlfriend were
walking on the beach Someday I'm gonna
do that it goes by in a Flicker and at
some point it's going to be over to me
heaven when we die is we meet that
person we were capable of being destined
to be and we're identical twins hell as
you meet him in your total strangers my
obsession in my life is when I meet that
dude we're going to be identical twins